from mozart to metallica
a talent show not short on range in
today's what's cool at school
home edition
oh my gosh it just it just really made
me feel
really glad that we decided to put in
all the work to do the talent show
because i'm like look at what we have
this is why it's called escobado's got
talent
the virtual talent show from escobado
middle school
featured 13 student finalists performing
everything from piano to poetry
to a mini metallica
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i loved how many different people were
doing it like there were so many
um guitar playing and poetry and singers
and it was just an awesome variety
the collective goal to uplift their
school community
even though we're not physically
together i at least wanted to have a way
for us to virtually be together the
reason for that is because they're
missing out on that socializational
piece that is so important to their
mental health
this was an opportunity to share a
passion for performing
one thing i really like when i play the
piano is the emotion you get to bring
into it
several businesses and families donated
prizes for the talent show winners
letting kids feel appreciated may be
needed now more than ever
the conclusion of this tale or shall i
say beginning
involves an intriguing crystal right for
the winning doing online learning
is hard because a lot of students need
the
social impact of it
[Music]
i watched the show um i was just i was
very proud i was proud of my staff
because they came together to make this
happen for our students and i
took a lot of pride in our students
[Music]
with her skills and the keys i did have
one request
kalei can you do me a favor can you
never stop playing piano
i promise okay and this is excavators
got talent
and that's what's cool at school